DC Universe Reapers the biggest comics
event of a 21st century the greatest
heroes and villains the greatest graphic
novels
the next epic starts here volume on
collections of the best-selling comic
books hello everyone I'd like your help
in welcoming Nicholas Scott to the stage
all right show me the Wonder Woman love
out there all right so Nicola can you
tell us a little bit about maybe an
artist that inspired you early on to
become an artist oh well I think
probably my earliest inspiration artists
wise was my mom because she was an
artist my grandmother was an artist and
it was my mom who taught me how to draw
she taught me how to paint and when I
was really young probably too young she
used to take me the life drawing classes
with her oh wow
and it was the seventies and um in you
know when I was really young she would
sort of draw these sort of beautiful
fleshy naked ladies and then you know
you draw them quite quickly and she'd
hand them to me and I put sort of big
Wonder Woman hair on them and draw boots
on them and said of Wonder Woman them up
a little bit and eventually she sort of
started telling me to draw the models
she'd sort of give me paper around
charcoal and tell me to draw the model
that's amazing
so um out of Wonder Woman what is your
favorite aspect to draw about her I just
look I more than anything I love drawing
her face I just love trying to sort of
capture the serenity and the strength
and the compassion of her expression
because while she's capable of
incredible fierceness I don't see her
the theists character she's she's more
accommodating and welcoming and
an accessible character one day she's
out goes out of a way to make herself
accessible I love that yeah it's
definitely a very expressive face as
beautiful so how many people have seen
the Wonder Woman inspired cake wars
episode from last year all right what
was that kind of experience about being
a judge on that show like for you um
I've done a couple of things like that
before in Australia but here the
production is way bigger you know in
terms of the amount of people on the
synthesizer does that and all that kind
of stuff and it was it was actually a
really fun day because everybody was
really friendly and really chatty and we
got to eat some really weird ingredients
and cakes like one of them was a chicken
and waffles cake
oh my god once again was a BLT cake and
the stranger the ingredients really the
more delicious the cake was wonderful
that's some of the the designs were
extraordinary you want at the end of the
day was fantastic it was amazing was
fantastic I think the winners baked the
cake that part of the special that was
filmed at the DC headquarters last year
as well that's right that was amazing
celebration and around Wonder Woman's
anniversary so what kind of advice can
you give to others out there that are
looking to become an artist in the
comics industry uh you really gotta want
to do it you've got to be really
passionate because the reality of the
job which is great fun it's a lot of
work you know all of us all of us work
from home much of most of the freelance
will work from home and it requires many
hours almost every single day of the
week and so that's that's quite the
commitment but the upside is that we get
to have a sort of creative outlet all
the time I get to sort of participate
and contribute to the legacy of these
amazing characters that have been around
for such a long time yeah speaking of
which what does it feel like to work on
this iconic character that has
around for like over even over 75 years
now at this point look from Wonder Woman
was the reason why I decided I wanted to
draw comics for a living and she's
popped up in in every book that I've
worked on but to sort of get to work on
her title and sort of do an in
continuity origin story during her 75th
anniversary in the lead-up to the film
coming up the the timing of it I feel
incredibly lucky and incredibly
privileged to be part of that experience
and and just are really lucky to be able
to share that experience with with my
great friend Greg Rucker and my new
friend Liam sharp you know as a team
we're really lucky to all be together
that's amazing yeah I love that and so
the whole collaboration project it seems
like you guys get to meet together but
then like you said you have a lot of
independent time to work on your craft
and have that creative outlet so do you
guys have like you know how does the
creative process of work a little bit
for you well to start off with like Liam
was attached to the book before like
quite a bit before Greg and I were and
when Greg and I sorry we're attached to
work on the book it was very it was
quite a quick turnaround
but luckily Greg and Greg and I have
loved Diana forever and so we talked
about her a lot we've talked about her
over and over and over again for 10
years with the hope that we would
eventually get the opportunity to do
something like this yeah but never quite
seeing when that might happen
always presuming it would be 5-10 years
away okay and when it finally suddenly
happened
we sort of had two action stations
straightaway and the three of us all got
on skype together and we had like a
number of really long marathon Skype
sessions where we just sort of talked
about the characters and we talked about
the theme and we talked about the what
what we all wanted out of the experience
and what we wanted for Diana and what we
wanted for Steve and what we how we
considered Aires and
you know everyone had really interesting
challenging things to contribute but
what was what was very clear from the
first moment was that we all got along
and we all understood each other's
motivation and it made for we you know
we were really lucky that you know we
got to have our team diner experience
all together that's amazing
and I remember talking to you I think it
was yesterday just about some of the
kind of the locations that you
eventually weave into the story in terms
of the artwork and finding one that was
even local to San Diego to make that
connection yeah and so is that usually a
challenging thing for you in terms of
the art when you have to consider all of
the surroundings along with the
characters as opposed to just focusing
on Diana and her and her beautiful
expressive face why I feel like a big
part of the fun of being able to create
comics is not only working on the
characters but the context that these
characters are in is what really sort of
adds depth and richness and layers of
meaning and when you can really sort of
indulge and invest in those contexts and
those settings and those backgrounds and
those you know little art backgrounds
yeah you know both Liam and I are super
into doing very detailed very well
researched very sort of in backgrounds
that are inspired by work by real places
by all these kinds of things that just
sort of it it makes Diana feel more real
when you can see her in a context so
sort of drawing her in in samus cara on
the island it's one of my favorite
things to do i it just made her whole
world open all the way up and and said
so much about who she is and then
you know doing that issue Tim where you
know when the script Gregg said it takes
place in a mall in San Diego and I was
like I know exactly what more we're
going to we're going plaza up the road
exactly um and you know that was that
was because I knew it but also it's it's
a great setting and it's visually really
interesting it's like an Escher if
anyone's ever been up there if you
haven't you should go out there it's
super confusing you'll never get your
way out of there again then um it's it's
sort of visually interesting because of
all of this weird architecture and
colors and shapes and just on the other
it's like I have to set it there it's
gonna be so hard to draw it but it's
gonna be really satisfying beautifully
yeah with all those different like you
said maybe the architectural lines and
things and that kind of symmetry that
feeds into it that gives the context for
the story do we have any question I can
take one question from the audience if
anybody has something for Nicola yes let
me come over to you what's your favorite
villain to draw my favorite villain
yikes
look I have to say I didn't have a lot
of fun when I was working on earth-2
drawing on Steppenwolf he is it's not
like he's the ultimate bad guy or
anything but he he's such an
accomplished warrior and there was
something quite satisfying about you
know this guy with an axe destroying an
entire Armada that's cool what does it
feel like to see your experience as one
character that you've been now bringing
to life on the page now you know come to
life in a very real way with the film
that came out recently well you know
like anyone who's been a Wonder Woman
fan for a long time we've been wanting
something you know we we've been lucky
enough to have such a fabulous
representation thanks to Lynda Carter
from the 70s show but you know like
everyone whose favorite character is
Batman or everyone whose favorite
character Superman that's
sort of new versions pretty consistently
and so we've really wanted a Wonder
Woman one and there's always been
something in development but you know
development and execution don't always
equal satisfaction and every time this
one was coming along you just sort of
cross your fingers and hope that it
would happen and that it would be good
and you know so many of them fell
through for so many different reasons
and then for one to finally sort of
actually get moving and move ahead
you're just like oh oh my god it's
coming and then or you hope you're so I
just hope it will be good and for it to
be as good as it was and blow everyone
away so so thoroughly and make such an
impact on the general audience you know
it's it's I was talking on the 175th
anniversary panel last year
upstairs with patty Jenkins and gal
gadot I I got to say um that five years
ago my favorite character Wonder Woman
felt like an old fashioned character you
know she was unless you read her comics
you were out of step with her she felt
you your memory of her with Linda Cotter
and it just felt old-fashioned where now
everybody is aware of how awesome she is
again and I love that you know everyone
is now sharing and experiencing how I
felt about it all the time that's
amazing that's so great
so like for some of I guess we have some
maybe new people to comics and to the
Wonder picking up Wonder Woman for the
first time what is maybe one thing about
Diana yet that you would hope them to
kind of pick up and field for themselves
um I think her her accessibility and
inclusion and compassion I think we I've
been talking about the movie so much
with all of my friends that I only get
to see here at comic-con we've we've
been just talking about the movie
non-stop because we love it so much and
a couple of my favorite lines from the
whole movie is uh they're there
the scene in the village once they're
all sort of celebrating their victory
and Steve looks around seeing everyone
happy and he turns to diner and he says
you did this and she turns back to him
and says we did and I just that to me is
Diana definitely so it's definitely
standing for courage but you know team
leadership everything it's wonderful
so I'll take maybe one more question
from the audience anybody have one for
Nicola and you think about Wonder Woman
anything that's been pressing you guys
know all right
um well so you have been I remember for
the filming like going back to the cake
Wars taping which is so unique and
really special and it was the finale was
filmed at the DC headquarters what is
like one iconic thing that you would
kind of point out it's really cool about
being there being weird like the origin
of a lot of these comics now come to
beam where they become live repeat the
question yeah so just lost track sorry
sorry I'm super jet lag no worries um so
just like being in the DC headquarters
like when it's said you see all these
you know team members working on all
different aspects of letting the fans
know about all the comics and just every
character that comes out like is there
anything that just stood out to you
about how the offices if there's a piece
of you know artwork are iconic you know
something on the walls that caught your
eye well look the offices are so much
fun you know I remember the New York
offices and they were pretty fun but the
the Burbank office is just extraordinary
you walk around and it's just fabulous
artwork up on the walls and and
maquettes everywhere and these amazing
statues and you know life-sized clock
hints and it's the whole place is just a
Disneyland
um but suddenly the thing that surprised
me but made me really happy and this is
really self serving with the the UN
Wonder Woman pasted up on the wall in
the lobby it made me really happy to see
that because I was so happy when that
was happening and really to
pointed when it when it you know was
taken away I feel like if it was
happening right now no one will complain
yeah yeah it was beautiful though like
you said the artwork is gorgeous and
everything so aside from her very
expressive face with Wonder Woman of
some of the iconic things about her even
a tire like her tiara her lasso of truth
even just the other aspects of her armor
do you have any other favorite like
items that you like to draw I feel like
what would appeal to me about Wonder
Woman initially like this is when I was
really young and I had never seen a
superhero before and suddenly Lynda
Carter was on my TV show jumping over
cars and throwing bad guys around was I
was I loved how instead of incidentally
glamorous she was you know that that
this costume was so bright and colorful
and it had all these amazing accessories
that did stuff you know like to lasso on
the bracelets I spent a good deal of my
youth sort of improvising bracelets out
of anything that I could lay my hands on
to the point of sometimes damaging
myself or cutting off my circulation
because I just wanted to have Wonder
Woman bracelets on all the time and
every time I had something on that was a
little bit like a Wonder Woman bracelet
I just be looking at my wrists non-stop
going doing the pose I'm sure like
everybody knows that oh yeah and I was
super proud when I was out of our six
that I felt like I had nailed the spin
so much better than any of my friends
Ben move it was I know you're doing it
wrong that's awesome so let's see out of
the DC Universe what character have you
not drawn yet that you might want to
take a stab at there are two sort of
really well-known DC characters that
I've had sort of very brief encounters
with that I would love to have quite a
bit more time with because I feel like
they're really interesting complex super
Leia characters
and I have something to say or to
contribute to the conversation and they
are Catwoman and Nightwing both good
choices
two of my all-time favorites I just love
them and I'd love to spend a little time
with them that's wonderful okay we'll
take one more question I guess for the
audience you have one do you feel there
any similarities between detective Rowan
black and Wonder Woman oh yeah by design
um so when I when I said I started
drawing her the the first sort of
sketches once I said have nailed the
idea of her look sort of giving her a
set of 70s kind of Joan Jett inspired
hairdo and stuff I know I wanted a
really soulful face and the only face
that I could think of especially the
eyes was Lynda Carter and so I was like
I'm gonna do that for myself I'm just
gonna give myself the opportunity to
draw Lynda Carter all day every day
and just you know waxham Joan Jett hair
honor but I see a lot of similarity
anyway because Wonder Woman is
essentially a very spiritually engaged
Hagen character you know and there is I
like when this layers of ritual that are
a part of her her spiritual identity and
there is an element of magic that's
intrinsic in Wonder Woman you know with
the lasso and and the invisible island
and you know I used to draw at the star
in her tiara with a circle around it so
it was like a pentagram protection and
so there are sort of visual things and
also spiritual overtones that to me
relate the characters quite
significantly and also because witches
by sort of European tradition are
sort of considered female lines you know
sort of female hereditary lines you know
sort of reminds me of that sort of
Amazon aspect and such so yeah that's
always sort of been a slight relation I
think that's why I found witchcraft
really fascinating as a subject when I
was in high school you know I sort of
did a paper for one of my history
classes on sort of witchcraft one I
think it was about 13 and it fascinated
me and part of that was how much I felt
like it related to Wonder Woman and so
yes absolutely there is quite the
relation that's great
can you tell us one I guess aspect
that's a little challenging to draw out
of everything that you work on like we
talked about the scenes the backgrounds
for actual you know expressive face at
different sequences what is the one
challenging thing that's always kind of
hard for you to draw the only time I
find myself going it's it's not so much
the execution that's challenging it's
just sort of more the idea every time
you have to draw something that you've
never drawn before you know cuz when you
work as much as we as we in the industry
do you just sort of build up a really
good mental visual library so you can
just sort of foot through in your head
you know what a car looks like you know
what and and if you have to sort of go
into specifics or or whatever it's
really easy to just reference but
suddenly every now and then you have to
sort of draw something really not in
your wheelhouse
and that can really slow you down but
because you it gives you the opportunity
to go into a sort of deep dive research
I think you know I'll sort of open up
open up Google Images and and see what I
can find and and look for references I
end up sort of being the most satisfied
with those pictures because they're the
ones that it's like I didn't know I
could do that until I
that's fast rate but sort of when it
comes to things that are really
important to me that aren't hard to do
but they're sort of take a bit of work I
really love drawing Wonder Woman's hair
like doing a sketch like this I get
really frustrated because what I would
like to do is just been an hour and a
half just giving her luxurious you know
shampoo commercial hair and I don't have
time oh it is up being super scribbly
and I just want to black it all out and
I don't have a wedge tip shopping that's
totally fine so just going back a little
bit to your process do you find you get
inspiration when you sit down to work or
before you sit down to work and say
going for a walk kind of taking in the
scenery or do you like to just kind of
unwind maybe the couple yeah look there
are different things that you need to do
to sort of keep yourself fresh yeah but
really inspiration wise I always said
whatever writers I'm working with that I
want scripts as early as possible I
don't I don't want to be sort of
starting on a script the day that I get
it I'd like to sort of read through it a
few times and if I can let let the ideas
and the themes of it kind of marinate
and come to the surface a little more
over a week you know it just sort of
really meditate on on what the writers
intention is because quite often they
they're not writing that they're writing
the dialogue and some stage directions
and you know that I I love subtext and
I'm always looking for it and sometimes
you know the writers don't write subtext
but it's it's there if you go looking
for it and um and so I like to just sort
of have that it's really just time it's
not doing anything necessarily specific
you know I could just be doing the
washing-up instead of dwelling on a
scene or an aspect of the issue which I
feel is important and somewhere in there
just sort of considering what I've read
a few times I'll think oh it's that
moment that moment it's not the moment
that I thought it was the B
moment it's the little moment just
before it or the little moment just
after it or whatever I feel like that's
where the gravity oh that scene is and
then it's it it makes me rethink the
whole flow of the scene and the
structure of the the layout and such so
if I can get as much time to do that as
possible
I'm always way more satisfied with the
result and and sort of the process as
well that's amazing
so going back to talking about yeah
drawing you her origin story and back on
her home of the mascara what is your
favorite thing there to draw and you got
to sit down and do that look paradise if
I could live in any existence I would be
living on Paradise Island
um you know I'd miss my husband but I
don't care because I love I love the
idea of a culture that has sort of
because they're immortal like in the
film they only really got to show cuz it
was a limited time they only really got
to show the warrior aspect but when you
consider this this nation of immortal
people that have sort of everything that
they create and develop it's about
sustainability it's about their
environment it's about them as a society
everything has kind of been elevated to
a high art because they've just been
around so long that you know this if
everyone is so skilled at everything
because I imagine every oh did I just
turn that off or turn it down you can't
oh you shut up back in your box the
there there's sort of I sort of figure
in my head that like every hundred years
they kind of rotate yeah you know it's
your job to do this now or it's your job
to do that or or they get to sort of
fulfill their their interests but it's a
it's very much community
and I love that aspect that everyone
sort of participating in their community
and that and the fact that it's like the
most beautiful place on earth like the
the island that they designed for the
film is so beautiful um you know I wish
we got to see more of the architecture I
wish we got to spend more time there I
you know I'm I want I want to pitch a TV
series like kind of Gotham and and uh
what's my color Krypton that's sort of
about the amazons on the island you know
about them arriving on the island and
and protecting the island and
establishing the island and you know
that them going from a warrior tribe you
know I think that's something really
interesting about a tribe of warriors
who have actively decided to remove
themselves from the theater of war
because they've decided that war Sox and
you know they keep their skills up they
know that you know they're never 100%
safe but they have sort sanctuary and
they're establishing it for themselves
yeah and somewhere along the line
they've managed to find immortality and
and grace on this island and you know
that that aspect to me is just beautiful
and so I just love drawing everything
about the island I love sort of finding
sort of real-world architectural
influences and then sort of upping the
game a little bit because you know
they've been there a long time that
managed to maintain these beautiful old
buildings and possibly grow them and
build more and develop their own skills
and and all that kind of stuff and I
loved what we were really sort of
conscious of when we would sort of when
Greg was writing scenes on the island
but specifically when I was drawing them
we said it's a it's not just a warrior
culture it's a culture of all women
and while they're all fit and healthy
and capable they're not all fit
supermodels you know what I was working
on the issues when the Olympic Games
were on last year and I was like if you
look at all the like an American athlete
athletes who were competing they go from
super tiny and compact
you know gymnast to sort of really big
muscly women who are like shot pudding
or or whatever you know that they're all
really fit and they're all really strong
but they're not all built the same way
that there is variety and that varieties
is represents us that represents all of
us you know and and that being healthy
doesn't necessarily mean being skinny
because some women are really built and
some people women are really tiny and
some people are really short and some
women are really tall and that you know
I wanted to sort of find that within the
community and give everyone some sort of
age variety so it's not as though
everyone's 25 on this island that's
awesome so as we wrap it up I do have
one trivia question for those that
joined us here today just as we've
talked about it for a couple times I
make it easy on you so by a show of
hands and I'll pick the first one I see
is so what show did she was she a judge
on last year for the Wonder Woman 75th
yes yes cake wars we went over here all
right help join me in thanking Nicholas
Scott for her stage demonstration today
please and whoo I'm pretty sure that's
what has happened all right thank you
guys so much for joining us too
you